you can experience the cloud just by
walking around San Francisco this fog is
just a Scottie cumulus cloud where its
faces up the surface but we don't think
of it that way we think of fog as this
gray kind of haze when it's actually
just individual cloud droplets that are
obscuring their view I think if people
realize they're walking through a cloud
that's probably the most important cloud
type on earth they might think that's
pretty cool
Vale's are complicated because there's
so many different types some are liquid
some are ice some are both some grow all
the way from the base of the atmosphere
to the top and there's seasonal timings
to worry about the biggest question that
cloud physicists are investigating right
now are how cloud droplets and aerosol
particles interact with each other any
particle and the atmosphere is
considered an aerosol you only make a
cloud when you have a particle for the
water vapor to condense upon in general
if you think of a cloud over the ocean
the majority of particles that serve as
the center of a cloud drop are usually
this combination of sea salt and some
biologically produced sulfur from
eligible if we look over land dust is a
huge component right because there's
lots of dust over the desert there's
lots of dust over the land and then for
industrial areas particles from safe
power plants or from industrial
processes wherever you are regionally
the particle distribution changes so
places where there's lots of virus our
clouds have smoke centers right the
smoke is actually amazing come amazing
and complicated because it does two
things if it's on top of the cloud like
in San Francisco Bay if they look down
from space with some lights coming from
straight from the bottom the smoke it
would look much darker so it wouldn't
reflect as much light back it would
actually heat the earth and that's
now eventually the smoke can actually
intermingle with the cloud and not only
does that change how the cloud behaves
it gives us a lot of other things to
worry about to achieved is whether or
not it rains which determines how long
the cloud will stay there if we start
infusing the cloud with more particles
we can have new particle formation and
have lots of smaller ones and now our
cloud looks brighter because now we've
got more droplets to reflect light the
strata cumulus example is great where
you'll have actually off the California
coast it's actually very easy to see
what the ships going to and from Hawaii
the ship track streak will be so much
brighter and it looks thicker and
fluffier then the cloud near it so when
it's above it makes the cut look darker
when it's intermingled it makes it look
brighter so it's a really complex system
because you can have both happening at
the same time so how much does one
cancel out the other it's really
complicated you can see that added smoke
and added particles from us doing
something as a species is changing
clouds it's not just there's lightning
and there's some fires the amount of
clouds that are on the earth determine
how much light is bounced back if we get
a rid of those huge cloud masses right
then there won't be as much energy going
back to space and the overall
temperature of the earth would go up we
have to know why it is doing what it's
doing right now
be better informed about how to
calculate what's going to change in the
future especially in regions that are
developing more people are doing farming
there's more there's more particles
being emitted and then that could
exacerbate the problem and maybe deplete
the cloud and then it gets warmer on top
of that the future of our work is to
really get an understanding of those
interactions across a range and of
aerosols and a range of thought types
the clouds are that important to what
temperature the earth is that we need to
know what those changes are
you